Do I look young and fun?
Cuz I am not.
*Oh no*
Hi! My name's Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now!
Welcome to my youtube channel.
I do a lot of fashion review videos.
I haven't done one in a little bit
And so why not come back with the fashion review
Of the Kids' Choice Awards.
Cuz there's nothing more fun than watching on YouTube
An adult critique children clothing.
Yep
Everything's good.
But let's look at the red carpet fashions at the Kids' Choice Awards.
I feel weird doing this, but we're doing this.
Heidi Klum
We're just starting right off with the person
That I cared about being there the most:
Heidi Klum
1: So glad that she made it.
2: The lower half is a very, like
"My kids made this for me as an early Mother's Day present"
And the upper half is like
"I'm still not over Adam Rippon not winning at Sochi figure skating" tribute kind of thing.
Cute!
Millie Bobby Brown
I think that this girl is incredible.
Even if she is dating Jakob S-
Young love!
And she's even more incredible because this outfit honored
The victims of the Parkland school shooting
Which on the weekend of March for Our Lives
Was extremely poignant and important
And it was really wonderful to see a young person not being afraid
Send a message to be involved and to use her platform
So Milly Bobby Brown, once again
I tip another gosh-dang hat to you for being...
Do you ever sleep? Cuz you're so woke.
Ohh, I'm so old
Caleb McLaughlin
Another young actor on the "Stranger Things" cast
Always looks so goddang cool.
This is like mafia tracksuit meets
Steve Jobs/Pharrell/2058
Like you're living on a different fashion platform than I am
A fashion platform that I can't even aspire to be
Cuz aspiring to something means that you think you could get there
No, this is just like out of reach, so kudos!
Maybe that's why I did not want to review the Kids' Choice Awards
Because it would just be too direct of a statement that
Ahh, they're just so good!
Dorm Reid
Who is in "A Wrinkle in Time"
If you have not seen it
I... this... how?
How are you this fashionable and put-together and perfect?
Just a-a-a little human bo-
Ugh, I'm broken.
This is so cool.
Also, your toenails look like you take care of them
And I to this day
Don't even know how to take care of my toenails, so
You're already, like, so far ahead of the game
This looks phenomenal
Great job. Great job! Great job.
Peyton List
This looks like you are making a list.
It looks like you're taking name
You look like a badass bitch.
I didn't mean to call you a bitch at all, whatsoever
I meant that in the highest regard
In that you look like a badass
You look great and powerful and strong and confident and...
Good job.
Yara Shahidi
This is so cute and elegant
It's very Shirley Temple meets modern day and
That might be the most advanced fashion parallel
I've ever made.
Should I quit while I'm ahead? No!
Let's bulldoze through this.
Also, you're wearing like seven-inch heels
And you're like maybe 17?
We're... okay. Good job.
It's very impressive.
Chloe Kim
US Olympic snowboarder extraordinaire
Look, she...
Get yourself a girl that can do both.
Like dominate effortlessly in snowboarding
And then wear frills like this and be like: "Oops!"
You're like a transformer
But like, one that I want to be friends with
Jaden Smith
Yes, layers, more
Jaden Smith's aesthetic is
Modern-day Broadway musical "Rent"
And I'm here for it.
Jaden Smith's aesthetic is:
"I'm going to win if we play strip poker"
"I have so many layers, you cannot defeat me"
I probably shouldn't say "strip poker" in a video
About reviewing Kids' Choice Awards fashion
So, that's good.
Sadie Sink
Also from "Stranger Things"
This is very "Wednesday from The Addams Family on a friday night
Meets, like, high-powered CEO
With a book club for women that are only on motorcycles"
Great job. You killed it.
Hailee Steinfeld
What is this magic act of a outfit?
You look like a magician's assistant
That was in the middle of one of those tablecloth pulls
And then you got "Oh!" distracted
Because someone wanted your attention
And the tablecloth got stuck in your pants
And you made it work
Also, you were having a... appendix erruption
In the most fashionable way possible.
Cute!
Mariah Carey and her daughter Monroe
*Mariah Carey New Year's Tea Meme*
Zendaya
Oh! You... wha-... ho-
She knows how to sh-... wha-
When you think she's gonna come cool, hip, modern
This is like "Breakfast at Tiffany's"
But I mean, like, your friend Tiffany
Who makes you breakfast after you've done a walk of shame
That's also not an appropriate reference for this sort of event
I'm sorry, Kate Middleton
But The United States has now proven
We have our own princess in our midst.
LaurDIY
It warms my god-damn metal heart
When I see you Youtubers on carpets for any awards show
You look like a sexy female gladiator
And I'm here for it.
Good job girl
John Cena
Who was I think the host of the Kids' Choice Awards
And I can't say anything about this
Cuz I have definitely worn some sort of variation of this
At some point in my professional life.
Yeah, this is like looking into a mirror.
Kristen Bell
You look like a high-fashion third grader
That's going on for her first day of, like, fashion elementary school
Cute!
Liza Koshy
Yes!
It makes me so happy
You're doing this cute red satin shorts suit
You look like a cool blackjack dealer
Super hip real estate agent
You're like: "I'm here for fun, but also business..."
If the monopoly man was updated and made into a woman
It should be this
Just putting it out there
Parker Ballinger
My heart is gasping and weeping and sobbing and screaming
Colleen Ballinger aka Miranda Sings' nephew
Walked the red carpet as Miranda Sings
And this is... I...
This is what the world needs.
Parker
You do not understand what joy and promise and hope
You bring to a world
That needs it the most right now
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you for this!
Okay. That is my red carpet review
Of the Kids' Choice Awards fashions
Let me know who, in the comments below
You loved at the Kids' Choice Awards
And what sort of fashion reviews
I should do in the future.
I'm open. Leave it in the comments down below.
Also do not forget to subscribe to this youtube channel
And click thumbs up and also the bell notification
Cuz I'm trying to make videos Tuesday and Thursday
But, ayy...
That was my impression of The Fonz
Which is a reference that is...
I'll pick it up cuz it just went over your head
I don't know.
Great job. Great job.
Also your toe nail
Like, everyone there
They get... they all... the pedicures
They all get pedicures and that's great.
Good job, you guys.